throughout the Second World War in
Europe there were many neutral nations
who despite their government's
intentions were unable to stay so while
some like Finland were able to resist
others like Sweden managed to avoid
fighting given Sweden's immense natural
resources notably iron it's even more
surprising that it was left alone when
the powers around it were fighting for
their continued existence not only that
but Sweden would have been a valuable
ally to whichever side it joined which
raises the question why didn't Sweden
join World War two and how did it manage
to maintain its neutrality and deter
aggressors so when the war broke out
Sweden declared itself to be a non
belligerent this shouldn't be surprising
since Sweden had been a neutral nation
since after the Napoleonic Wars this was
mostly because it was forced to hand
over Swedish Pomerania to Prussia and
thus had nothing binding them to
mainland continental politics
thus by 1939 Sweden had over a century
of neutral foreign policy stances behind
it it was governed at this point by per
Albin Hansson who was doing everything
in his power to keep fascist or
communist sympathizers away from power
his government was a coalition of four
major parties and their foreign policy
goals at first was simply don't get
involved in the war yet as many of you
will be aware the war soon came to its
neighbors Finland fought the winter war
against the USSR and in 1940 both
Denmark and Norway were conquered by
Germany for the Finnish Soviet Wars the
Swedish were sympathetic to Finland and
there were even some who called for
Sweden to formally get involved hansom
resisted and so Sweden covertly gave
money and weapons to the Finns and
roughly 12,000 Swedes crossed the border
to help in non-combat roles as for
Denmark and Norway Sweden wasn't willing
to go to such lengths to help them
resist Germany and this was largely for
economic reasons
Sweden exported masses of iron ore to
Germany throughout the war and given
that everyone else had been conquered
there was no other customers in case
you're wondering the reason why Germany
kept buying the iron instead of simply
conquering Sweden was a Hitler assumed
that the Allies wouldn't bomb a neutral
country so the only reason that Sweden
was able to stay neutral was that it
made concessions to both sides for
example when Germany conquered Norway
the Swedish government allowed German
troops to travel through the country
they also allowed German troops to
transit the country to Finland in 1941
when Germany invaded the Soviet Union
this actually led to what's called the
midsummer crisis where ministers
panicked over what to do because they
really didn't want to be seen aiding the
Germans in the war with the USSR in fact
Sweden's King Gustaf v said that if the
Germans weren't accommodated then he
personally would not be willing to bear
the consequences and so they allowed
German troops to cross and throughout
the war over
two million German soldiers did so of
course Sweden couldn't just give in to
what the Germans wanted since at that
point they may as well have just been a
member of the axis and as such Sweden
was sure to aid the Allies too for
example it took thousands of Jewish
refugees from Denmark and all over
Europe as well as giving refuge to
socialists and political dissidents and
furthermore Sweden also took to covertly
training Norwegian troops in its
territory they were also active in
conducting espionage against Germany and
fed troop movements and industrial
information to the British in the
Americans and in the end Sweden's
neutrality in the war carries a
confusing legacy avoiding occupation and
bombing was the priority for the
government and they did achieve that
they did so by facilitating German troop
movements and providing it with valuable
resources with which it could power its
war machine that said what real choice
did Sweden have Denmark or Norway were
conquered for reasons of strategy and
the Germans would have happily done the
same to Sweden and Sweden was sure to
balance this were evading the Allies and
giving refuge to Europe's persecuted in
the end Sweden state neutral by doing
just enough to avoid the ire of both
sides I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching with extra
thanks to my patreon supporters which
you can see on screen and with an extra
special thanks to James Bissonnette
David archaeologist Ozark a flash Party
Boyko Rob Waterhouse Chris wicker
Michael Reynolds Gustav Swann David
Silverman spinning three plates
Maggie packs Kowski Christian check'
Anthony Beckett Ike Skye Chappell and
Winston K wood
you